not just the pandemic this year it's
everything seems to have been a knock-on
effect for me like losing my mum and
then the pandemic hit and it's just i
lost my jobs
i it was it was horrendous it's been
horrible
it's been really really really
frustrating and it's hard to keep a
straight face
and smile and wave at everybody because
i don't want to smile i don't want to
wave i just want to have the nice things
that other people have
something going to happen where we get a
chance to come and do what normal people
are doing
it's frustrating
it's hard work living on on a poverty
you know what i mean and that is what it
is it's first class poverty i was poor
before the pandemic nothing's changed
nothing's going to change
[Music]
that is exactly how i feel and boris
johnson just doesn't help i can't even
watch the news and listen to him anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
it's absolutely soul destroying
and then he's going on again today about
a higher wage and where is it it's going
to take a few years
we're still going to be on the bread
line earning nothing and living on
nothing just paying your bills
[Music]
good morning everybody listen isn't it
amazing to be back here in person
on the day the prime minister delivered
his speech to the conservative party
conference
five and a half million families had
their benefits cut by an average of a
thousand pounds a year it is our mission
as conservatives to promote opportunity
with every tool we have
just four days earlier the energy
companies raised the price of
electricity and gas for 15 million
households
and a few weeks before that
inflation made its biggest jump on
record sending the cost of food and
drink spiraling
i feel like i just want to give up but i
don't i keep going for my kids because i
have to i always thought the harder you
were the better off you'd be but it's
just not quite like that
we've spent time with three families to
see how this affects them as they try to
prevent a winter of hunger and hardship
they are among millions of others right
across britain who will be worse off
this winter
and that could have huge implications
for the government's big domestic
ambition
to level up britain
[Music]
no blow up
open the air raise it up in the air and
blow it
not give everybody a shower robert and
laura and their two children dylan and
lacy
are heading into this winter with bills
piling up around them let's see you blow
some bubbles then
no blow up robert's part-time work as a
security guard has dried up
and to make matters even worse
a mix-up with their benefit payments
through no fault of their own
has left them penniless for the last
three weeks
just literally been a complete and utter
nightmare
and
i've been struggling literally
struggling through just to try and sort
it it all means that you're now behind
on a lot of bills you're in you're in
rent areas you'll have electricity and
gas coming your way
food and christmas yeah how do you feel
when you look into the next few months
this winter coming
not very good at the moment because
i feel like i'm not going to be able to
afford to give them the christmas that
i'd like to give them or anything and
it's literally
basically nearing off destroyed as
anything
but we're just trying to keep it
together for the kids aren't we as well
robert is desperate to help his family
all right i'm off to see abc in a bit
and he's come up with a plan that he
hopes will solve the problem you know
yes
see you later
180 miles away in bristol helen knight
and her daughter freya are just about
making ends meet
vicious
she's vicious now
helen works at the post office she
relies on universal credit
but the 20 pound a week uplift that the
government brought in during the
pandemic has now been taken away
before the pandemic and before the
uplift i was already drowning a little
bit trying to keep on top of things and
the the uplift was was actually like
someone chucking me a life jacket i was
really pleased that we could kind of bob
along and just just get by feels like
someone's kind of burst that jacket food
wise because when we go food shopping we
can't get as much as we used to be able
to get
so
that's come down quite a lot
and
it's obviously
food's getting a bit more expensive what
would your message be to to the prime
minister and to the government it's not
really that fair on the people that do
work hard
because then
that's gonna make it harder for them
and their families
fuel has increased food has increased
which you've noticed
clothing has increased everything's
increased so it's not the same as it was
and i was already struggling
[Music]
so i will do whatever i can to protect
people's livelihoods and create new
opportunities too
[Music]
what do you want to be when you grow up
baby i want to be a marine biologist of
course you do the year threes didn't
take me seriously anymore they don't
take you seriously anymore
jackie and jason live with their three
children kade marshall and skyler
jackie was working a few jobs before the
pandemic hit
i lost all my jobs at the beginning and
they were only little a few hours in the
evening but that few hours in the
evening was our financial support that
was our safety net on top of that
everything's going up the cost of living
the gas the electric which i'm already
feeling since the first
but just before you got here
it just went
just before you got here and then
minuses always in minuses so you're in
your standby you're in your standby
from the first 15 million households had
to pay more for their electricity and
gas
the energy cap designed to protect
customers from price hikes has been
raised to cope with a global surge in
demand for energy
how much do you think it's gone up by
about um well i used to put about 15
quid on each
a week and now i think it's going to be
at least 25 easy because it's nearly
doubled like how much it goes out how
quick it goes down
this week
the electorate's gone three times
already since
friday last week
it's it's gone through since the prices
went up yeah and i've been looking and
you noticed that straight away oh
straight away straight away
yeah it'll beep and tell me when it's
low and that's my biggest fear when you
hear that beep beep i'm just thinking
jesus we don't get paid till next week
how am i going to do it what happens
when you turn the other day are you
ready for this
for the last year the oven hasn't worked
so jackie's cooking for five on a single
hob
are you at the end of your tennis i'm
really on with it i really am
yes as soon as it comes out we're going
on thursday morning to take it
robert's come to his local citizens
advice bureau in derbyshire for help
after his benefit payments stopped
suddenly advisors have managed to
establish that it was an administrative
error i think it's quite a dire
situation for robin's family going into
these winter months because they've lost
four weeks of tax credits money
so they'll be in debt to some degree
they're in rent areas already and they
can't afford to buy food or keep their
home the energy costs rise will be a
major issue for these people
i think those three wasn't there they're
gonna be able to carry all these yeah
i'll be able to carry it robert is
promised that his benefits will be paid
the following day
he's given some food parcels so his
family can eat
i feel like i just want to give up but i
don't i keep going for my kids because i
have to
would you like to come this way please
jackie and jason have also come to
citizens advice to see if they can
access a grant to buy a cooker
but they're also struggling to pay their
energy bills and they're behind on the
rent we can't deal with it all at once
it might might feel like a little bit of
a tidal wave for you
i'll catch up with jackie and jason
after their meeting
once i've done the gas the electric and
the food shopping there's basically
nothing left if i sit here and think
about it i just sit here and cry because
what else can you do what else can i do
there's no help there's nobody there
nobody looks at us that are struggling
do not mean it's all about oh we'll get
off your ass and get a job what jobs
what jobs can we get i've tried
everything
absolutely everything
we will get on with our job
of uniting and levelling up across the
uk the greatest project that any
government can embark on
the pandemic has delayed the
government's big promise to level up
britain they say that means creating
jobs investing in public services raised
living standards
but this winter threatens to make
millions of families poorer than they
already are
does that mean this plan has stalled
before it's even begun
jake berry is a conservative mp and one
of the leading advocates of the north at
westminster he calls boris johnson his
friend whilst at the same time suggests
that he'll turn on the pm if leveling up
doesn't materialize
let's just start with a sort of good old
traditional definition of what you think
leveling up actually means
well a guest point isn't what i think it
means the challenge with it is it means
something different to everyone and
that's really dangerous in politics well
look we're here in this beautiful town
of darwin in the heart of my
constituency it's the recipient of a 25
million pound government town deal and
already if people come here they can see
improvements to the town centre better
youth facilities so we kind of get what
it is here because we're already is that
level
absolutely so let's just take darwin
then have you got tangible evidence to
say that the improvements that you've
seen that you've just described
make people more prosperous
improve their lives and make them a
little bit more on par with their
counterparts in the south so is there
any evidence there the answer is
absolutely no
and that's the great challenges and
that's the big challenge with our dear
friends and chums at hm treasury is they
will only spend money
when you can put a tick in a box or show
them a statistic on a spreadsheet that
shows that spending that money is adding
to uk gdp or whatever measure you need
so what you've described so what you've
described in darwin you began by saying
what's leveling up perhaps isn't
leveling up yet it is it is but it's
just too early to say
so leveling up is still quite far down
the track
in the short term to help families the
government says it's devoted 500 million
pounds to a winter hardship fund this
winter is really important for millions
of families the government is making
these big decisions on on leveling up
throughout its conference and at the
same time we face a leveling down of
living standards ippr estimates that
many families will lose up to four
billion pounds in the next six months
because of rising fuel prices rising
food prices cuts to universal credit and
the government's support package of 500
million pounds is far too small to rise
to the scale of this challenge well the
government says we are committed to
levelling up we're running through a
white paper on leveling up we're
investing billions of pounds on leveling
up we want to
invest in roads rail and housing and
jobs and job creation they've been
saying this for months are you saying
that
this is not
working
there have been many false storms on
leveling up it's not the first agenda
that seeks to address regional
inequalities it is a golden opportunity
if it rises to the rhetoric
[Music]
i think the next few months are the acid
test for levelling up
of course leveling up whatever shape it
takes won't pay the bills this winter no
one expects that it's a long term idea
but a perfect storm this winter could
inflict real damage on the very families
that leveling up is designed to help
[Music]